Being a superhero
is a trial by fire who's gonna protect
the world it's not people like you
i'm jennifer walters i'm a lawyer i have great
friends can we get some shots please it's an
emergency a demanding job we just started a
superhuman law division and i want you to be
the face of it and a frustrating family
because we didn't ask for this but you
still got to deal with it your transformations
are triggered by anger and fear those are like
the baseline of any woman just existing oh rude
i feel like if i don't transform i'm gonna die
yes yes yes no no i just want to be a
normal anonymous lawyer can you tell
us where she-hulk is jen you're a story
now girl your ass looks crazy right now
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
is there anything more depressing
than dating in your 30s
yeah this is the best date i've had in a while oh
should we split some fries let's get those to go
Welcome back everyone big surprise marvel
dropped the she-hulk trailer so we'll break
it down there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs obviously a lot going on with the
hulk daredevil is supposed to appear during the
series we have abomination a whole bunch of other
marvel characters i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes so be sure to subscribe to get everything
starting with the beginning obviously it's the
new york city landscape because that's where most
of the series takes place she's a lawyer by day
four superheroes people with super powers as they
kind of tell you during the trailer daredevil is
kind of the same idea which is why they both run
into each other as lawyers during the day at the
courthouse and as vigilantes by night for those
of you asking this is taking place after the
events of avengers end game this isn't meant to
be during the five-year time jump or anything
like that a lot of people wondering when she
gets her powers and how she gets their powers how
close to the comic book origin that's going to be
there'll be nine episodes total and it seems like
bruce banner's hulk is a big part of the early
parts of this although he might be in the later
episodes too just teaching her the ins and the
outs of how to handle her gamma powers and how
to be a hulk it also sounds like in his voiceover
dialogue he's trying to inspire her to be a
superhero eventually join the avengers someday
but she doesn't want to have anything to do with
that like who wants to join the avengers that's
what he means when he says being a superhero is
a trial by fire who's going to protect the world
if not you there is a car crash that we see during
this and that might have something to do with her
origin story the reason she became she-hulk in
the comics is because she was his cousin which he
references during the trailer like hey cuz how's
it going she was in the middle of a trial trying
to deal with some mobsters eventually they came to
kill her she was injured at the hospital needed a
blood transfusion and bruce banner just happened
to be nearby so she got his gamma abilities
through that blood transfusion just based on the
footage it seems like they're gonna go with that
version of the origin story with a couple twists
but when they're intercutting with his voiceover
dialogue you see this giant party with all these
troops going crazy with his special weaponry it
seems like she-hulk rolls up to this party as she
hooked like in full she-hulk form and she goes
crazy at some point or there's some super villain
activity here there's a couple scenes where you
see small groups of people with weapons seeming
like they're coming for her so they're probably
going to be some of the antagonist groups during
the series aside from the abomination in titania
they haven't confirmed who all the villains are
going to be during the series but the whole idea
is that it's nine episodes long so episode episode
will feature a couple different trials that she's
involved in so i think most of the villains
will show up through those different trials
that she's involved with as a lawyer one of the
funny things though is you kind of see through
the trailer there's a lot of scenes where she's
walking around in broad daylight in full green
she-hulk form like eight foot tall woman just
walking around like it's no big deal even though
she-hulk can actually go back to normal human
form unlike bruce banner's hulk most of her time
is spent walking around as actual hulk the one
difference in the mcu is that post endgame he
sort of found a way to become the professor hulk
version of the character the chatty version of the
hook normally in the comics that's not the case
like the professor hulk era was relatively short
but that's basically what she-hulk is going to be
like she'll be walking around most of the time in
she-hulk form but because there's kind of a jokey
tone to the series like it's kind of comedic
they're going to play with the amount that she
hulks out throughout different episodes like when
hulk is testing her abilities she really hulks out
like she starts to get really pissed off and crazy
that's the more powerful more mindless version of
the hulk inside her but the rest of the time where
you see her walking around about half strength
that's how she'll be through most of the series
and they'll just have jokes about her really going
crazy most of you who are longtime comic book fans
will notice that the costume that she's wearing
in her she-hulk form here is comic book accurate
they have a custom version of the marvel studios
logo that's green for the hulk the actual logo
for the series is designed like the classic
hulk titles and a bit of a twist on classic
lawyer advertisements like they're billing the
actual full title as she-hulk attorney at law
even though my videos will just be like she-hulk
episode 1 she-hulk episode 2. there's a couple
familiar faces at her law firm obviously a lot of
her day-to-day will be dealing with being she-hulk
while still trying to be a lawyer most of you will
recognize tatiana maslany from shows like orphan
black she's fantastic actress so i can't wait
to see what she does with the character probably
one of the other biggest things during the trailer
aside from just waiting to see daredevil as actual
daredevil during the episodes is them finally
revealing what was going on with emil blonsky's
abomination during the shangshi movie so it looks
like post end game when everybody was blitzed
back at some point they built a special prison for
superhuman individuals or people with superpowers
who are accused of crimes like abomination
usually the people that are too powerful to
exist in regular prisons are the ones that go to
the raft but it sounds like they've changed that
in present day but now we know what was going on
with wong versus the abomination during shangshi
so when they were fighting they seemed kind
of like friends like wang was trying to earn
his sandwich money he did earn some money and he
was trying to help abomination learn to chill out
so now we know where he opened the portal to
at the end of their fight he went back to this
facility and the actual cell that he went back
to is designed like the hulk cell from the first
avengers movie just like an upgrade from that and
for those of you asking they did confirm that wong
is coming back for she-hulk episodes probably
something to do with what he was doing with
abomination during the shangshi movie one of the
huge differences though is that we actually see
him in human form like it's actually tim roth
in human form one of the big differences from
the abomination in the hulk is that abomination
cannot change back to human form in the comics
and i talked about this back when the shangshi
movie first came out but obviously they've changed
the way that the abomination looks since the last
time we saw him during the incredible hook movie
he's just more comic book accurate now that's what
the finns the razer sharp teeth are it just meant
it looked like abomination in the comics it seems
like she's going to be responsible for defending
these potential super villains at this prison
here like the abomination is one of her big cases
that she has to do even though they've established
banner is a hero around the world now because he's
become professor hulk he started helping people
he's been less destructive so people like him just
in general they're not expecting him to destroy
everything it seems like the reason he would take
her to this remote tropical island to test her
gamma abilities and learn about everything is just
to prevent as much collateral damage as possible
because she doesn't fully understand how her
powers work yet she's not meant to be a scientist
like bruce banner though she's just like a normal
lawyer so she is very intelligent but she doesn't
know a lot of the science of everything that's
where a lot of this comedy comes from between
the two of them like he's pulling out these giant
binders trying to explain everything in great
detail she's just like no no we don't have time
for this this is too boring they confirmed that
the special lad that he has is in this tropical
remote area and he's trying to teach her how
to hulk out and then come back to human form
without completely destroying everything freak
her out with all these blades trying to get her to
hook out and then she really goes crazy it seems
like she winds up destroying a bunch of this lab
they're using a couple different types of
technology to show her when she's hulked out like
they're using practical effects but they're also
using a little bit of cg replacement like they use
for the hook like the hulk when he's hulked out
is full on cg but it seems like some of the scenes
of her hulking out is meant to be practical like
the old school 70s incredible hulk tv series they
even had the funny clip from the last series with
them doing a fake advertisement for her law firm
but doing the iconic hulk line you wouldn't like
me when i'm angry mr mcgee don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me when
i'm angry don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me when i'm angry when she's
making the joke with her friends about not really
caring about being an avenger she says oh that's
for billionaires narcissist she's talking about
tony stark billionaire philanthropist playboy also
a really big narcissist you could really call most
of the avengers narcissist as well the joke about
adult orphan you could make about a couple of the
characters because most of their parents died when
they were young like even iron man's parents died
when he was young thor's parents got killed black
widow was also orphaned at a young age so really
most of the avengers are adult orphans in some
way then the big scene of her hooking out in the
courtroom and attacking someone is actually her
going up against titania she's going to be one
of the big villains during the series she's a big
she-hulk villain from the comics i'm not sure who
this green person in the costume is it just seems
like one of the other super villains that she'll
run into during the course of her different trials
there are a couple funny scenes of abomination
hooking out in this small space i'm hoping they're
going to have some funny rematch scenes between
him and the bruce banner version of the hulk even
though obviously it was the edward norton version
of the hulk that he went up against they're
meant to be the same version of the hulk it's
just a different actor so maybe they'll have some
jokes about that i'm also hoping that eventually
abomination will show up on the thunderbolts team
hopefully there'll be some teasers for that in the
back as well because they're going to be dealing
with so many different super villains and that's
basically her stock and trade is finding people
with a specific set of skills quote unquote like
other super villains to do things for her that
she can't get the regular avengers to deal with
and they end the trailer on a couple tinder jokes
about her just trying to find someone that you
could actually legitimately be with while she's
an 8 foot tall woman like who's going to find
8 foot tall woman attractive and turns out there
are actually a lot of dudes out there that love
that we won't do any kind of kink shaming here
if you're into that that's totally cool there is
a person named kevin you could think of that as a
kevin feige joke like kevin feige shows up on her
tinder profile i'll say is that dude that's going
to get with she-hulk is probably going to get
wrecked and he will probably enjoy every minute of
it just make sure to take him to the hospital when
you're done with him she-hulk is gonna wind up
smashing that dude something fierce as far as we
can tell there's no daredevil in this version of
the trailer they'll probably save him for a little
bit later on but i think that eventually we'll see
matt murdock in some of the footage just to get
people to go crazy if you have any questions
about what's going on with daredevil during
this or the other characters or what's going on
with hulk just in general in marvel phase four
just write it below in the comments my obi-wan
kenobi episode videos will start next week too
that'll be like the next real big thing so make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss that everyone click here for that brand
new thor love and thunder first look video of the
marvel gods vs gore the god butcher and click here
for my other really big she-hulk trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!